yo
bootleg podcast black zach in here
south carolina's own um zach
first of all let's talk about all the
jewelry you got on bro yeah
that's a lot my g you got the obviously
you got the custom band on there with
your name on in this shot i never saw
that
yeah um so aviana he he made this like
from scratch like
he got the dm me in the dial is that a
rolex yeah it's a rolex cousin
i played like 124 i probably overpaid
for it but
i just want to be the first one with
some [ __ ] like that that's a hundred and
twenty thousand dollar watch 120
damn what about the other one something
lighter
yeah my brother my brother brought this
for me for my birthday he brought us
from i think it's
like this is jubilee it's like 30
something like that
man your brother's a nice guy yeah for
so
yeah and then obviously you got every i
mean how many chains you got on bro
oh i only got like three i ain't really
like when i travel i don't really like
bringing all my jerks
that's very smart yeah i'm like bringing
all this [ __ ] because this would be too
much of a hassle
if you had to estimate how much money
you have invested in jewelry what would
be your estimation
like 750 800 000 do you look at jewelry
as an investment
um at first i was just i ain't even
gonna lie to you i was just doing it
because at first i seen like
but this before like i all the rappers
was really really
getting into i mean i used to see like
the the migos and [ __ ] all the time like
they'll
be at the jury stone and i'm like damn
this is what the rapper's about to get
into like jerry so i just started buying
it
like but then as i learned it i had to
learn like
watches is what keep value watches and
cuban links and [ __ ] like that so i'm
like man i'm about to just start
buying like watches and cuban links and
stuff like that
i heard that if you flood your watch
though it takes away from
the long-term value is that true yeah it
do take away for for um for some watches
but right now like how to how to like
how the pandemic and stuff is from what
the jewelers tell me like he be trying
to buy my ap
from me he'd be trying to buy it back
yeah he was trying to buy back just for
saying like
everything loan everything right now oh
wow
that's crazy do you know it's
interesting because we're in a a point
in time
in in in the world where there's people
out here that are real desperate
to hit a lick does that make you you
just said that you don't move around a
lot when when you travel with all your
jewelry
are you worried about like you know
being out of state or being out of town
and like you know
[ __ ] in texas benny got shot boozy got
shot
you know yeah 2020 but craig it's been
crazy are you
like does that make you change the way
you move around because you're kind of
known to have
a lot of that's kind of like a you know
thing a lot of people know but has that
has that made you re-evaluate that at
all
i mean i feel like nobody untouchable
but i just feel like
you know it's all about like what you're
going to do after your [ __ ] get took or
something like
anybody can get some jury took or
something but you got to just handle it
how i come
and you got to know how to move like i
don't be in places around got no
business or
wow why i shouldn't be there at a time
so
have you ever had any sort of incident
happen like that where maybe someone
tried to catch you slipping
no no not gonna work yeah yeah we can
knock on wood
yeah well um you got the project out you
first of all you dropped two projects
this year right
yo caroline naco i dropped kerala naka
like soon as the
yeah it's like as soon as i dropped
caroline i go to pandemic
it was crazy like i was i had so much
[ __ ] like lined up because
i did a short film um i had like
um the money bag your tour set up yeah
yeah
yeah the baby toy was set up in my own
tour but as soon as it happened like the
pandemic
hit and just said everything so much
live money taken away from everybody
so much live money especially someone
like baby who was about to have a crazy
festival run
for show yeah baby you know baby gonna
make that money regardless yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah um so yeah i mean i think that
that's also a dope thing it's like
a lot of people have taken advantage of
the fact during the pandemic like and
just have been dropping
even more music than they usually would
because it's almost like you got to make
up for
the lost bread like why sit on the music
people i feel like now right now people
are listening to music more than ever
and they're listening to it differently
if that makes sense
exactly i guess they'll appreciate it
more and ain't nothing else to do
but make me yeah um 803 legend
um south carolina
you from columbia columbia yep that's
where charlemagne started his radio
career right yeah first shout out to
man early on he was in i don't know if
that's where he necessarily started yeah
i think you're from
like something to south carolina or
something like that much corner
something yeah i think that's close to
something though charleston no it's
about charleston
maybe he was in charleston not not not
yeah charleston but yeah he most
definitely was um he got ties in
columbia for sure
yeah yeah um i was just talking to
carter about
kind of like the carolinas in general
being they're such an
uh important part of of rappers careers
that we don't even acknowledge because
of all the radio stations that are in
both of those states
and it's almost like you can't really
find an artist
that is really popped like without
having that region unlocked yeah
yeah and it's crazy because like like
the carolinas there you know they'll go
crazy like
when like anybody else come but it's
like it's it's kind of weird like when
you from there i guess it's like that
everywhere
it's just like that everywhere yeah i
don't really use that as excuse but most
definitely like
carolina's be one of the first places
where all the people come
and make their money though for sure
because they gon they gonna book them
the promoters gonna book them and
people gonna show up and go crazy for
them 100 what do you
how do you compare north carolina versus
south carolina is it like what's the big
difference
if any um like north carolina a little
bit more kind of
advanced like we only got no nfl team
right
like the biggest y'all just claimed the
panthers because it's just carolina
panthers
yeah it's kill our panthers the owl what
the street so that's all we got in it
only thing like columbia got is uh like
the
gamecocks like the usc yeah i remember
seeing those hats as a kid
and it would just say [ __ ] on it and
i'd be like yo
fam yeah what is going on what school is
this
yeah yeah i'd be at the lids and it'd be
a hat that just said cox on
i'd be like bro what the [ __ ] oh this
south carolina gang cox they should put
the whole thing on there
that's so crazy um
it is
[Laughter]
so you aligning yourself with
uh with carter and arnold and those guys
what point in time did you sign because
you were making noise prior to that
obviously but at what point in time
did you make that affiliation official
um
i say about i beside like the smg
as far as like probably like a year and
a
half
two years something like that so it's
been a while i think it's dope i was
just telling carter this i was like yo
the fact that like
all of the artists over there are from
the carolinas
yeah it's so special see i think on a
planet that [ __ ]
like i think he just wanted like all his
artists to be from carolina whether it's
south and north carolina he want all his
artists to be from carolina
yeah because if you're in his position
you could sign anybody yeah yeah he can
and anybody
probably be willing to sign yeah and now
now it's like just the fact he's he
that there's just such a intentional
effort to put on
the carolinas are special bro like i
think it's super dope
um now you're obviously uh you you
obviously have
a lot of money that might not
necessarily be rap money
um what like
what would you you know there's up and
coming artists
who make mistakes who
you know yeah got one foot in one foot
out you know what i'm saying like
you seem to be doing very well for
yourself and you seem to be fully
entrenched in the rap game now but what
would be some advice you would give
to some up and coming artists that might
be watching this that might kind of
you know still have one foot in the
streets one foot out like you know what
i'm saying like what
oh basically i tell them just invest
their money like don't be cheap like
you know i'm saying don't be like if
you're gonna
do the rap like you gotta put like
at least 95 in that [ __ ] yeah you're
saying like reinvest
your own money into your rap yeah put
your money like reinvest your money into
your career like
because you got to show people that you
serious and before they even willing to
put money
into you like most people like to be
like they'll go buy some cushion not
even want to go pay for studio time or
something like that like that should be
backwards but
get a whole goddamn that's when i
realized like
i was doing [ __ ] backwards like when i
realized i was like hold up
man i got like a four five thousand
dollar outfit
and i'm i'm getting a thousand dollar
video man
no i gotta flip that around yeah like
that's if i'm willing to spend this on
clothes i gotta be willing to spend
double that on something to take my
music career to the video to the next
level
exactly like but [ __ ] people don't be
understanding that but
see they'll figure it out who's the
first uh big name or big artist that we
might know that like gave you a cosign
early on um like
probably young dolph dolph thoughts the
realest bro
yeah dolphin always silent dog what year
is that
that probably was like 2015
14. potted sooner than probably earlier
than that i can't really remember but
because i had did a song with him a long
time ago but
you know i was like on some young [ __ ]
still one foot in one foot out
so you know he probably did a song with
millions of people but he probably like
what i'm thinking happened is with me
keep going up
like i kept going and we ran into each
other again
and he was like damn that's like a
different conversation it was difficult
to say like dennis
little buddy who no i'm saying because
back then i paid him man you had to cash
him out for the verse yeah i'll catch
him out for the break i paid him in all
fives and tens like trout money
so he already knew like back then so
when we ran into each other again he was
like damn he's still grinding
what was what was the the ticket on a
doll first back then
i think we're like i think i paid him
like 8 000
then i paid him another 10 for the video
though yeah you got to double up for the
video
yeah y'all playing the team i was like
[ __ ] like i used to love like giving
these
i used to look at everybody like rap
[ __ ] but now i i'm a rapper i hate
when somebody call me a rotten egg
because i feel like kind of like
you trying to discredit somebody but
just because [ __ ] be rapping like that
they don't mean they ain't solid most of
these [ __ ] someone
saw that not not all alone but
um obviously coming from your background
talk about what's the biggest l you've
taken in the streets man
because i you know everyone's i mean not
everyone but you know you
dabble in that world you know that
sometimes you take a l sometimes the
package you get lost in the mail
or so you know whatever it is yeah one
time see i lost like
250 [ __ ] this year i lost like 180
but i don't trip about it so you lost
250 000
one time at one time what what okay give
us as much of the circumstances you can
give this without snitching on yourself
just some [ __ ] getting lost he got lost
that's what
he got lost so i guess you know what i'm
saying but
we got a shake back from people don't
want to hear you complain yeah bouncing
back from a 250 000
l brush that's that's that's rough
what how did you like the 180 this year
what was that same situation
not some this is some other [ __ ] damn
that's some man i got someone broke into
my car this year
yeah and took 15 000 in cash out of my
trunk bro while i was in a notary
yeah that's it that [ __ ] hurt yeah hit
different though you know
i'll be looking at it like i don't care
if i lose a thousand or
hundred thousand that should still hit
the same yeah especially if someone
takes it from you bro
yeah if you want to kill somebody yeah
like god
damn like but i guess you know bigger
the risk of
the reward but one thing about me like
when i always lose that type of money
like even when you know because me my
mom and my mom recruit
i tell them i'm doing everything but i
won't be like man every time you always
bounce back from me
and i always like i lost i remember i
took a big air
and then that's when uh arnold called me
it was like endoscope wanted to sign
and he told me to know how yeah yeah so
every time i always take a loss i'll
bounce back from like
god who blessed me was way bigger than
what i lost it's like you took the l and
then you signed the interscope right
after
exactly like you know what i ain't even
tripping yep and that was one of the
biggest losses i
ever took in life like i always probably
lost like a little 30 here right right
yeah
yeah yeah but that was the biggest loss
and then right after that i'd say like a
week later
and i had a show like when it happened i
had a show in virginia
man i was about to go home like i ain't
even want to do this [ __ ] up your whole
[ __ ] move
man that [ __ ] [ __ ] your whole vibe up
like we got girls and all
around i'm like man [ __ ] these hoes like
i ain't even been thinking about that
[ __ ]
yo what's crazy is like the reason why i
really really resonated with baby's
music early on was because i felt like
he did such a good job of talking about
selling weed like the packs and [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying i felt like
i'm i'm talking about even before that
obviously sugar was huge but even before
that like
like i was like yeah i've never heard
anybody rap about selling weed
that i'm i could relate to more than
like burner you know somebody like that
but yeah shout out to burnley but he
would but baby told me that he used to
sell
the uh he would used to vacuum seal up
rabbit food
rubber full yeah right which is
dangerous you get caught slipping
did you ever dabble in any sort of that
no i ain't never did i did screw it up
in this
i ain't never like i ain't really been
into that world like
not knocking somebody who'd do it but no
i do straight up business i ain't never
really had to
rob it for this yeah cause i was like
damn bro like
i'm glad you're still here yeah yeah you
made it through it
because that kind of [ __ ] man you you
sounds like rabbit food to the wrong
peoples
they gonna kill you in south carolina i
don't know about knuckling but you would
have got your ass about it even
right now especially how big he is it
wouldn't work i saw something where he
said you were the richest rapper in
south carolina
man the crazy thing is i ain't even
named myself that like
the um like the people was commenting
that like way back
just commenting on my instagram so i
made it a song
and ever since i made a song like that's
when everybody just been calling me that
[ __ ] but
ain't nobody never challenged it so it's
like [ __ ]
financially do you uh do you like to
dabble in any sort of like real estate
investing businesses like
what like you got like i mean you know
you got a lot of [ __ ] jewelry yeah
damn that's a that's just like really
for trophies and [ __ ] but
like i do real estate like we got smoke
shops i might
open a restaurant restaurant for like my
family but i just built my crib like
like from the dirt i built it like it's
just from the mud and
like oh that was always a goal for me
like
i want to build a house so you know i'm
saying i be into that type of [ __ ] like
real estate like i ain't no food like i
ain't just doing like
buying jury doing dog [ __ ] and [ __ ] like
that was there ever anything you bought
that you regretted buying like like
immediately after
like something that was just like [ __ ]
man what did i just do like
oh no i can't really think that i've hit
like saying something i regret no i
can't really think
how has um how's your experience been so
far with the interscope situation
it's been cool like you know it's still
like it's a real good umbrella you know
and
a good machine to have with you but it's
like it's still on the artist it's still
on you you still got to
heat yourself up yeah exactly you know
what i'm saying i feel like
you know a label know what how to take
something that's it's already moving and
make it yeah make it bigger
but you know i signed my deal for
different reasons so
you know i'm saying like i still i come
from the independent game so i just know
how to i'm still moving around
independently like i ain't
ain't with a major yeah plus not you got
all your independent catalogs it's gonna
keep going up
you know yeah and that's a good thing
they did for me too they they let me
keep all that [ __ ]
that's that that's important because you
become you know
yeah the next baby or whoever like that
independent catalog gonna go crazy
forever
exactly that's dope man so 803 legend
who else can you kind of give us a
breakdown of like the hip-hop scene in
in
in south carolina specifically because i
feel like
like you were saying earlier a little
bit like it's almost harder to
like get support from your own people
until you start popping
and everybody want to come and jump on
see not like people fought with me
in carolina like no offense out but at
first it was like
i used to feel like i was it was me
against everybody but you know
because like it was like how i came
in in this [ __ ] like especially at home
but how it came out it was so
like unreal's like ain't no way he doing
it like that other than
like if you like in my immediate circle
then you notice
but other than that it's like man the
way he doing like that like
so it's hard for them to try to support
it or want to support it but
and then you gotta think we're coming
from like that [ __ ] is
it's a little country time so it's like
ain't nobody major
ain't nobody major came from out of
there like
the closest one we had was like little
roo yeah
[ __ ] like that little rule and that's
about it and i forgot about little real
yeah you know what i'm saying you never
really got to that that level like this
the biggest like the carolinas they ever
been like
period like south and north like that's
the biggest it don't been because
like when arnold even with like honor
did what he did but even with the artist
like me and baby got
a a a relationship where it's like we
kind of bridge the gap to
north and south carolina how long have
you guys had uh that
like because obviously baby
independently been running [ __ ] for a
long time
you know and then but like how long did
you like like did you guys have a
rapport like prior to you signing
for sure yeah yeah i i knew baby like
five years ago right right probably like
five years ago like we went to the
studio together
it was just him by himself me and my
brother put up we did like four five
songs that night
i being new baby then like he used to
see me coming out there in the clubs
running around throwing money doing
stuff he'll do the same thing
and you know like that's why he showed
me the type of love he showed me because
he know like what i'm talking about
like that boy really doing it like he
really comforting so that's why he
always showed me love anytime i
anytime i need him i can call him i just
called and asked him about some
some [ __ ] the other day he pick up every
time yeah that's big man
yo what's up man boulette kev here shout
out to the homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love
man and let me tell you something we
don't take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right
um i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now
and um man christmas time coming up make
sure you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design no license but just crazy so
make sure you get some of those all
right
then they got the nickelodeon they got
the uh scarface they got tapatio
they got wwe how about chef from
southpark you know what i'm saying
whatever you need
shout out stone cold steve austin by the
way these are the socks that i wear when
i uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife uh
anyway um shout out to old dirty bastard
too
go to oddssoxofficial.com right now
all right right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
what did you learn in the streets that
you've been able to apply to your to
your music career
um just try to like outwork everybody in
the streets you gotta have the best
number
so you gotta outwork everybody so in the
rock game
you know i'm saying you gotta outwork
everybody and try to have the best
product in your lane
like i learned my lane like as far as
like with the track [ __ ] i feel like
that laying wide open
like it's kind of like died down because
people doing all the singing [ __ ]
and all that type of [ __ ] but me i'm
gonna come in with my own flavor like
like i like how jesus and guccif came in
back in the day i'm a new generation in
there like
because ain't nobody really gonna ain't
nobody talking to track [ __ ] like me
and get back it up yeah nobody it's
crazy because the new trapping i feel
like during the during cover 19 is the
edd [ __ ]
edd whatever deployment [ __ ] oh
that's what they call them [ __ ]
are eating out here
that's crazy i gotta be thinking like
god damn like
i got a homie of mine who like he's
pulling out like
you know five figures of death at the
atm off these cars
bro yeah i need some of that free man
it's crazy
but my granny told me like hey anything
free ain't worth taking i was like
they're like is they gonna have to pay
that [ __ ] back what they're so like
nah what they doing bro is they're
finding homeless people
and cashing them out for their
information oh okay okay so you find a
homeless [ __ ] you say look i'll
give you a rack give me your id and your
social media
and then all at that point in time it's
almost like moving packs in the mail you
just need an address to get the card
sent to
exactly the [ __ ] is crazy that's just
crazy damn that shit's wild yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i feel like that's the new like
that's the new
hustle you know what i'm saying shout
out to him shout out to him man
uh i'm i'm assuming i mean obviously uh
803 legend is out
uh carolina narco is out um
i mean i'm assuming you already got a
whole another
project yeah i'm thinking i need to go
um i got another project ready but i'm
i'm thinking about dropping their own
deluxe
before the end of the year out for uh
for eight or three legends
shopping deluxe probably add like three
new songs
with some features no i just like i got
some hard [ __ ] with y'all school to like
hey scooters doesn't get the props he
deserves yeah
we came up we came up like uh listening
to school like scooter's crazy
yeah yeah yeah you know he i feel like
he one of the ones too like
i used to like i like pee wee long way
too but i just you know what if you know
every long way is the other one yeah
with them type of people like if you
know you know like
you could tell they still for sure yeah
they still moving and grooving but at
the end of the day like see
i guarantee they they situated like they
ain't i ain't impressed by it
ain't hurt besides pee-wee and scooter
who's the artist that you came up
listening to while you was
moving around that you were like man i
know that what they're saying is real
cause
they that's that like you said is that
if you know you know [ __ ] is anybody
else like that
um like dopey all right pw
r.i.p man yeah don't be with five like
that one of my
favorites it was crazy lost too soon man
yeah he was so young like
like well he had alabama on his back
you know what i'm coming from that
country town i know how i feel like
just having to beat them eyes and his
his content around like what he was
rapping about like
you would think he was like 30 years old
when he died when he was like 22.
he was like young kid man yeah so he he
had a crazy vocabulary
what what's something that about you
that people don't know out there like
what
what's the hobby of yours like what do
you you know what's a hidden talent
maybe just something that we don't know
about black zach that people might be
surprised about
i cut a [ __ ] as in 2k okay i was about
to say i thought you were going to talk
about like you stab somebody like
nah nah 2k you're great at 2k
yeah yeah
you're nice on the sticks yeah for so
even the new 2k
sucks though they changed the the shot
meter i ain't gonna lie so
i love 2k 20 but it's 21 that's why i
ain't playing i
switched the whole [ __ ] up i brought the
ps5 just to say i had it but i swear to
god i played that [ __ ] one time did you
overpay for the ps5
i overpaid how much you end up paying
1200 that's fair
i was getting them off for about 12.
yeah yeah it was the asian dude like in
atlanta he had like
fifth of them joints i'm like god damn
what he
he posted a picture i don't know if it
was what if it was real or what but
then they had like fit them and we
brought like three on from them
[Music]
everybody yeah yeah i was telling them
to a lot of people out here
yeah yeah i said i let you then you
should have man i knew you had
i had them so are you are you the house
you just built was that in is that in
atlanta or carolina isn't it
yeah i wanted to goddamn build my [ __ ]
home because that's where my kids at and
stuff yeah yeah yeah
yeah well listen man 803 legend um
deluxe coming soon for so for sure for
show
you and the whole crew going up right
now yeah shout out to
shout out to beat matty the baby
stanford vegas you have your own
uh imprint as well because you know
baby's got a billion dollar baby like do
you have your own crew that you're
working on
yeah i got um my [ __ ] called dme
um i got fat load on lil quail campaign
dirty monday sunday like
all those people like they grinding they
still like they making noise back at
home from south carolina yeah for so
there it is man well yo go support this
guy's project and
damn man i'm i'm heartbroken after i
heard you took 180 000 hell this year
that's a lot
that's a lot my stomach hurts for you
but yo go support it man we got the
freestyle too dropping uh we gonna drop
the freestyle like a few days after this
drop so go support the homie black zach
tap
in real night well it's not real 92 3
it's the bootleg kev
podcast tomatoes tomatoes